je savais dans ma classe moétais délégué
Deass je vous l' déjà dit donc en fait
je faisais des réunions avec des relous
commass pas toi je t'aime bien maisant
je t'adore et un jour ils ils ont voulu
ces bâtards sa ce qu'ils ont fait je
vous raconte à 18h54 ils ont voulu me
destituern je te jure
V pource que vous aviez fait ils ont
voulu parceil ont dit ou il sert à rien
truc c'est quoi ce délégué de classe
tout ça parce qu'en fait je peux le dire
aujourd'hui j'ai magouillé ah l'élection
des délégués une Dara j'avais deux
copains qui s'appelaient je les embrasse
Soufian radwani j'embrasse et Jalal et
la veille je l' réuni chez moi Jeur dit
les gars si on soit sortir cette année
il faut que je sois dé on prend le
pouvoir il faut que je prenne le pouvoir
sinon on est mort je dis tout de suite
et il y avait un autre gars avec nous je
me rappelle ouais il avait une meuf
s'appelait Sandrine qui était très bien
vu genre un peu un T et genre ouais tu
vois et donc j'ai dit il faut qu'on
appelle Sandrine Sandrine de elle
s'appelit je faut la faire venir à la
maison faut faut qu'on lui parle je dis
ouais qu'est-ce que tu fais et tout je
suis à la maison je dis ouais est-ce que
on peut te voir et tout j'ai peut-être
un bon truc pour la classe c'est pour
redynamiser un petit peu la classe comme
on est en début d'année tu vois j'ai
peut-être des idées tu vois dis vas-y
d'accord j'arrive je dis bon demain il y
a les lection des délégués je t'explique
en fait l'histoire c'est quoi c'est
qu'il y avait des papiers qui se
présentent et il y a les papiers donc
que tu dois mettre dans une un dans une
urde ou dans une trousse on les mettait
commandou et donc on est avec la prof
principale et je dis à sandR
toi la meuf quand tu vas dire voilà
est-ce que moi je peux récupérer les
papiers toi elle va te dire oui donc
qu'est-ce que j'ai fait j'ai pris on a
préparé les papiers la veille les faux
papiers avec que cyil Anouna oh là là
pas ESS qu'estce qu'elle a fait son rine
elle a pris les faux les vrais papiers
pendant qu'elle redistribuit et au
dernier moment elle a mis les papiers où
j'étais moi et là la prof elle arrive
elle fait le dépouillement cyil an
Nouna ça démarre bien
alors on av mis d' dur ah quand même ah
Stéphane
Galati serré cyil
Hanouna cyil
Hanouna Anouna est délégué et là c'est
la récré et il y a tous les gars qui
disent tu as voté pour
toi oh fermez vos gueules maintenant
c'est fini les gars oh il y a pas de ta
beuté pour qui pas véas pas voté c'est
terminé c'est fait c'est fait allez
dégage allez c'est moi le délégé
donnez-moi CAH de texte cahier d'app
jeis parcex CAH d'appel com en dictateur
maintenant c'est WAM le chef de la
classe maintenant ou Chérif il y en a un
qui bronche frère je lui fais je mets la
misère toute la vie voilà je dis qu'il
était pas là tout ça je m'en fous je
mettais des faux mots sur le cahier
d'appel voilà je et après je Tai délégué
j'ai fait ça 3 ans de suite 3 ans ah ou
et il y a une année à chaque fois avec
les les arnaques comme ça à chaque fois
il y a une année ils ont voulu me
destituer je te jure
c'est honteux ça il sont ils disent
ouais il un gars il vient me voir come s
dit ouais je vais te destituer je va
destituer il dit ouais tu vas voir on va
faire un PCH il il a réuni des élèves tu
me rappelles Cyril en pare et tout un
gars il fumé je me rappelle quand avecun
chemée comm c'est tout ouais il dit
ouais on va te destituer on en a rien à
[__] tu vas faire quoi to il dit ouais
je fais du karaté maintenant ferme ta
gueule écout ils ont essayé de me
destituer qu'est-ce que j'ai fait mais
qu'est-ce que j'ai fait non mais en
faisant quoi ils voulaiit faire quoi
pour vous destituer ils ont voulé ils
voulait aller voir la prof principale ah
ouais et moi qu'est-ce que j'ai fait je
suis allé voir le proviseur ah oui ouais
ouaisouais est-ce que je peux voir euh
Monsieur le Proviseur ave un petit souci
et tout j'ai l'impression que il se
rendent pas compte du travail que j'abas
en tant que
délégué non mais sans déconner il paraît
qu'ils veulent me destituer alors que je
fais tout pour eux quoi la semaine
dernière c'est moi qui amène les les les
les cours d'histoire à la maison chez
nom mais sans déconner chez Bertrand
Chartier je vais tout pour eux et voilà
quoi vous avez pleuré non mais je dis
c'est comme ça qu'on est on est
récompensé là c'est donc finalement pas
de destitution proviseur est arrivé oui
Cyril adouna a été élu délégué il reste
c'est une décision du peuple il sera
délégué de classe jusqu'à la fin de
l'année quoi vou dtituer
à et vous savez qui était à l'origine de
la destitution non Sandrine de Har oh oh
et oui les gars et oui l'intérieur tout
ce que j'ai fait pour elle c'est moi qui
changé deses carreaux des lunettes non
sur ma vie chez carglace n'importe quoi
non mais je te jure elle a eu des
scrupules peut-être à TR ouis peut-être
les remords peut-être ah mais il s'est
passé quoi c'est bon quoi il s'est passé
quoi c'est pas possible qu'elle balance
comme ça au bout de 3 ans elle vous avez
lu pendant 3 ans dans la magouille et la
trème année elle ve pas tu sais pourquoi
elle est amoureuse de vous non elle
voulait êre délégée elle voulait être
délégée on pris le bail après ou alors
elle est amoureuse ouruseouruse du tout
était pas du tout amoureuse éta vou desl
de classe moi j'étais pas du tout
làdedans moi j'étais pas dans les meufs
et vous vous êtes expliqué avec elle
quoi bah avecph Sandrine comment elle
s'appelleit Sandrine une explication
mais qu'est-ce que je m'en fous j'ai dit
je suis délégé fermez vos gueules en
fait je texplique j'ai dit voilà je suis
arrivé dans la CL je dis voilà qu'est-ce
qu'il y a maintenant je suis délégué
voilà c'est à moi que vous reportez tout
voilà maintenant c'est tout vous avez un
problème vous reportez donc voilà c'est
qui a un problème ici tuas pas beaucoup
changé
de qu'il ça faire
quoi
on un problème on a un problème on vient
vous voir par vous nous dites ferme ta
gueule on repart pas
beaucoup franchement ça s'appelle le
dialoguecoup CH mais franchement qui a
été délégué de classe Mo voilà été
éluy non c'est vrai à la loyale fort
j'adore mais il y en avait deux délégués
par le SU tuétais malade aussi j'avais
un gar Mo avec moi tu avais un gar avec
toi aussi moi j'étais titulaire et
j'avais quelqu'un avec moi ouais ouais
ouais c'est ça j'aimais bien
trs à cur vous organisez les soirées du
BDE et tout euh non parce que j'étais
plus petite dans les petites écoles
c'était pas à l'école de commerce BDE
vous aviez vous bien sûr l'école en
seconde et tout ou bien sûr il y avait
des soiré il y avait au lycée vous aviez
un
BDE même
trésorier demand cotisation premère
voiture Ilère mais c'est moi qui r moi
j'avais créé un BD il y en Ava pas mais
je dit les gars il faut qu'on fe un truc
fait des soiré avec un siège social sur
les champs che
je que c'est vrai l'histoire est vrai
sans déconner incroyable bien sûr
j'avais cré un j'avais dit vas-y c'est
quoi on fait des soirées tous les mois
je faisais une soirée je je disais voilà
vous donz boisson à volonté et cetera
j'ai acheté deux bouteilles
d'Oasis coup ça 40 balles personne non
non mais tu es fou non moi c'était plus
pour les conseils de classe des les
camarades voilà ça bien sûr aller parler
au professeur est-ce que vous défendiez
vos camarades quand même au conseil de
classe non le truc le trucs qu'il faut
faire quand vous êtes classe je vous dis
la vraie darka c'était quoi c'est que en
fait les mecs t'appellent le soir du
conseil de classe parce que tu es le
seul à savoir ce qui s'est dit ou oui et
W donc les gars m'appelé et dans un gars
qui travaillait genre yamb et tout ouais
ouais
Thomas alors comment ça s'est passé bah
pas ouf he frère oh non comment ça j'ai
j'ai 15 de moyenne général ouais ouais
ouais ouais ouais mais ils étaient pas
trop sur les moyennes en fait ce qu'ils
ont dit que tu avais vachement baissé
toi par rapport au premier trimestre et
tout ils ont dit tu perds encore deux
points au 3è trimestre ils s'en battent
les couilles ils ont dit maintenant
c'est par rapport au niveau que tu avais
au départ si tu redoubles ou pas moi le
truc qu' part c'est moi j'ai démarré à 4
là je suis à 6 ils ont dit ouais jeis tu
vois toi ils ont dit ouais tu vois 17 15
ouais attention ou pas donc je sais pas
non je sais pas par contre tu es
toujours copain avec Nicolas gracien a T
de travail frérot et ouais ouais il a
peut-être 18 de moyen général mais av
ver t de travail ou bah ouais ouais
ouais bah j'ai pas pu le défendre
ah je te jure je disais que des
conneries il arrivé le lendemain frère
pas du tout ce que tu nous as dit bah
les gars je me suis trompé de classe je
me suis trompé de classe est-ce qu'il y
a une hérédité chez la Nouna est-ce que
votre fils est délégué votre fille est
délégé non non mais je crois qu'il y a
pas ils sont pas délégés to tu étais pas
délégé toi déléé ouais tu aurais é B pas
ou quoi oui mais
pas 14 ans non jamais délégué je
détestais les délégués c'est des faillot
mer moi j'ai été délégé j'ai eu un
avertissement de comportement c'estàd
qu'en fait j'été délégé un peu Kaira et
les profs me détestaient donc en fait j'
assistais à mon propre procès le truc
traves mal délégé c'est très ouais ouais
et non comportement aussi par que
au-delà de pas très bien travaillé
j'étais très bavard très dissipé donc en
fait les profs ils supportaient pas mais
comme c'est les élèves qui votent ils
votent VO ils avaient voté pour moi la
loy moi j'aurais voté pour toi bah oui
parce que les les gens
m'appréciaient à cette époque à l'école
je t'urais kiffé on aurait fait des
trucs de ouf ensemble c'est je voudrais
dire à Léo et Joan bravo je suis pour je
suis pour oui
vous oui oui bien sûr bah oui moi
j'aimais bien défendre oui bien sûr
longtemps plusieurs années moi je
défends les enfants en difficulté mais
les enfants frère enfant toi aussi ah
oui bah je
défendraisfend mes collègues enulté hier
cons j'aimais bien ouais ouais tu me
battais pour eux et tout ça ouais ouais
j'adore c'est beau toi j'urais aimé
tuurais aimé comme toi en class je
t'aurais détesté pourquoi ah obligé toi
pourquoi tu es un relou arrête un peu je
suis pas du tout relou to tu es le genre
de gars tu fais comme e si vous avez pas
envie d'apprendre déécoutez pas les
autres c'est ça ça délégué que je
déteste moi vous vous étiez devant ou
derrière en classe vous étiez plutôt
dehors dans l'autre classe derrière je
passais s des fois des fois en fait
parce que moi il y avait des vitres
comme ça et et les prof voyez les gars
qui passaient et et parfois moi je me
promenais en fait dans le dans le lycée
tu vois je passais commass et la prof
elle me voyait sait pas comassou elle fa
une touté commass elle sortait
qu'est-ce que vous faites non parce que
là j'ai j'ai un pote là qui est pas bien
en 3è Deb là s'est senti mal donc je
vais le voir là mais je reviens Contin
continuer le cours je reviens dans dans
15 minutes je vais voir ce qui se passe
d'accord je fais un petit tour je suis
en patrouille dans le lycée puis
j'arrive après mais je suis sû que les
prof il vous aiment bien quand même
parce le le branur inquiétez pas il
avent peur non moi j'étais au premier
rang toujours premier r prier toujours
pour faire illusion bah bien sûr si tu
es au dernier rang frère tu ét cramé
direct mal premier et quand tu es
fracasse en classe tu connais quand tu
es fracasse et la technique quand tu te
mets commass
si tu réfléchissais avec le livre devant
frère je suis frère j'étais comme mais
frère mais pas je dormais mon frère mais
mais mais vraiment mais éclaté et parfis
tentendis quoi non mais ça va pas te
gueuler comme ça oh non je c'est comme
ça je m'en vaisité ah je dis je m'en
vais je pars comme je pars j'ai pas aimé
le
comportement j'ai pas aimé le
comportement je partais comme non je
préfère qu'on se quitte en mon terme
avant qu'on s'embrouille c'est ça partez
quand je dis on colé souvent ou pas
ouais bien sûr ou de colle et je me
rappelle moi j'étais collé des fois
samedi dimanche les de j'étais dans une
école un moment j'étais dans une un
moment plus personne voulait de moi
c'est vrai dimanche et malheureusement
mes parents ont dû me mettre dans une
école privé cé dimanche et sans charer
je vous dire de pou demander à ma mère
j'étais collé dimanche matin parf ça
c'est chaud ça làas vous étiez pensionna
non non non non mais 8h du matin je
devais dormir là-bas frère je peux te
dire je partais à 7h c'était dans le 14e
Charlemagne je peux te dire j'en ai pris
des tané ah oui c'est une boîte à BAC
ouais pas cétait une boîte à bac mais
j'étais le seul à pas l'avoir c'est bo
et après je suis r rentré dans le dans
le public ah ouais vous un parcours
scolaire intéressant quand même saz
comment je suis rentré dans le public
non non par la porte alors je le dis
faut pas le faire parce que normalement
quand tu es dans une école privée tu
peux plus rentrer dans public ou ah oua
ah bon ouais j'ai je suis rentré dans le
public parce que j'ai je suis en j'ai en
fait j'ai appelé je me suis à l'époque
pourquoi vous murmurez ou c'est très
maltion à l'époque j'ai appé le ma de de
Paris je me suis fait passer je vous
jure que c'est vrai me suis fait passer
pour je vraiment
me Tib et je je me suis fait passer donc
j'ai appelé j'ai oui je vous appelle de
la part du bureau je sais plus qui était
le ministre de l'éducation à l'époque
j'ai appelé j'ai dit voilà truc il y a
un élève qu' faut absolument reprendre
dans le circuit normal tout ça ils ont
dit ouis mais non mais il faudrait qu'on
le voit et tout faudrait qu'on le voit
il faudrait que truc qu'est-ce que j'ai
fait j'ai dit à ma mère tu vas les
appeler et tu vas dire que tu es la
secrétaire du ministre votre mère ma
mère l'a fait vous voulez que j'appelle
ma mère ma mère l'a appelé elle a appelé
elle est venue avec moi au rendez-vous
là-bas et j'ai été repris dans un lycée
vouleis que j'appelle ma mère oui votre
maman FAM génial c'est génial ouais je
vous dis avez déjàour dans votre vie
sans tricher non mais l'histoire est
vraie et ma mère elle m'a elle m'a elle
m'a régalé incroyable
ouais incroyable ouais dis-moi dis la
vérité on n pas on s'est pas fait passer
pour le ministre pour retourner dans une
école éco mal on s'est pas fait passer
pour tutais pas fait de passer pour
l'assistante du ministre pour que je
retourne dans oui oui oui oui oui ou oui
oui
oui à tout à l'heure je raconte pas
d'histoire moi la tête de ma mère c'est
vraitoire est
vraiouler çaneries on va pas parler de
ça il y a ses goèes qui arrivent dans un
instant
on se rrouveant à tout de suite
non